This means that only with flavors that
are completely artificial and
have nothing to do with naturalness, even if they
can often be declared natural, with
flavors and any acidifying agents
you turn them into something tasty
that people eat and that is of
course extremely bad because
in the end you are using pure sugar  That means
you can
seduce people with additives, you can ultimately get them
used to something like that and
in the end that's extremely bad for the body and
that's what happens in the
food industry D because it's
cheaper to replace real cheese
with a cheese flavor  That's
how it's done and since I do
n't even see it on the packaging because
I can then declare it as a natural flavor, it
's often done
and that's why we eat
poorly